فداه مقتل اربعه من الامريكيين بينهم
السفير كريستوفر ستيفنز اثر حصار دام لمده
اربع ساعات على القنصليه الامريكيه في
مدينه بنغاز الليبيه تتواصل المظاهرات في
العديد من الدول الاسلاميه للاحتجاج على
فيلم مثير للجدل تم تصويره في الولايات
المتحده واعتبر مسيئا للاسلام وتقول مصادر
امريكيه ان المسلحين الذين هاجموا مبنى
السفاره في ليبيا استخدم المحتجين كذريعة
وقد تصاعدت الاحتجاجات في المنطقه حيث اخذ
الناس بالنزول لشوارع في نحو 12 ع بلدا
ففي العراق سار المئات بمدينه الصدر وسط
بغداد وهم يهتفون بشعرات مناهضه للولايات
المتحده بينما اصيب بمصر المئات من
المتظاهرين اثر الاحتجاجات قرب مبنى
السفاره الامريكيه في القاهره اما في
اليمن فقد اخترق المتظاهرون الجدار الامني
للسفاره الامريكيه بينما كان هناك الالاف
من الشبان الغاضبين امام المبنى وادانت
وزيره الخارجيه الامريكيه هيلاري كلينتون
اعمال العنف بينما عبرت عن اشمئزازها من
الفيلم وقالت هذا الفيديو مثير للاشمئزاز
ويستحق الشجب ويبدو ان غرض الفيلم كان
السخريه وتشويه سمعه ديانه عظيمه ولكن لا
يوجد اي مبرر على الاطلاق لمجابهتها
بالعنف